Speaker 1: We're continuing our look at whether
or not Fox News is abandoning Donald Trump
in 2024. The answer seems to continue
to be they're not abandoning him yet,
but they've got an ejection and ejection seat
and they could pull the lever at any time if it
looks like things are going to go the direction
of Ron DeSantis. Here is yet another example.
Stuart Varney interviewed Mitch McConnell's wife,
Elaine Chao. Elaine Chao was attacked by Donald
Trump for her ethnicity. Now, multiple times
he's referred to her as Coco Chao. And what is
interesting about this interview is that Stuart
Varney says, I mean, months too late, but Stuart
Varney says we were all appalled here at Fox
News when Trump spoke about you that way, not
sounding very Fox News like. Let's take a listen.
Speaker 3: I want to talk about inflation in a
moment. But first, former President Trump attacked
you on the grounds of your ethnicity. I wonder if
you'd like to take this moment to respond.
Speaker 2: Well, the president says many
things. I don't make a point of
responding to his comments. Okay.
Speaker 3: I'll leave it right there. We were
all appalled at what he said, and it's up to you
what you said in response. Thank you very much.
Speaker 1: We were all appalled by what he said.
So this is kind of interesting. There are
people making too much of this. You know,
the first thing is if everyone at Fox News was
appalled when Trump said. This about Elaine Chao
in what was the exact date, the very beginning
of October. It's almost the end of December
now. So they hid the they kept to themselves how
appalled they were about what Trump said until
mid-December. So if they were indeed appalled,
they were not super eager to make it known. But
this is yet another one of those you don't really
have to read further into it. Then at face value,
which is Fox News is maintaining a certain
distance from Trump under notice that even since
announcing that he was running in 2024, I don't
believe Trump had like a serious interview on Fox
News. I don't even know if he's appeared at all.
Fox News is keeping a respectful distance to Trump
while continuing to have pro-Trump and
anti-Trump voices from the right on the
channel. Fox News doesn't know the direction
it's going to go. We know that the Murdochs
would prefer someone other than Trump be the
Republican nominee and ultimately president,
and they're just leaving themselves that
possibility open. It's not the biggest deal,
but they just want to be prepared with an escape
hatch if indeed the tide truly turns against
Trump. That's what's going on here. Let's not make
more of it than it is. But it is something that
that's the way FOX News is approaching the 2024
primaries so far. We'll have all of these clips
that I played on our Instagram, which you can
find by searching Instagram for David Pakman show